we had a new addition to the practice
it's just so weird
[Music]
going back home
I hate it they're like bad emojis stop
petting my patience with those we liked
it
we just want a little fist I don't want
oh and you're not funny oh I wish I had
a little glass of wine
like I hate these it's okay just be
relaxed just relax just let me give you
a pat on the shoulder you're doing a
good job I had so much
you know if you can't make work fun why
work I was already having fun
oh is that itchy I'm Dr Joya and skin is
my specialty oh your Skin's peeling off
when a mystery pops up that case comes
to me let's start looking at you things
are looking better this job can be
sticky gooey and stinky but I love every
moment of it I love this amazing turn
around
[Applause]
all right Coco let's go
it's all good girl Coco loves new people
it's almost like she wants to see how
much attention she can get from a new
person
she looks at you with those eyes and you
just want to give her what she wants
she's a great great dog
when we first got our a year and a half
ago she had heartworm she was very
lethargic and we weren't sure what was
going to happen but medicine worked Coco
got over the heartworm and I made it a
goal to get back her cardiovascular
energy so we went hiking every day
little by little Coco has regained her
energy
she's come a long long way
good girl
but after about a month and a half we
saw that Coco had a like a big bubble on
her head hi Coco all of a sudden we were
petting her and you can feel that bump
yeah the vet said it actually was a cyst
yeah and that it would keep growing
until we got it aspirated yeah
instead of going to the vet
for the rest of her life every month to
get this aspirated or potentially having
it pop on us I'm hoping that Dr Julia
can remove the cyst and Coco can live
her life without having this big ball on
her head once the fluid inside look like
um clear clear yeah my fear is that
it'll turn into something cancerous the
biggest thing would be to just get the
whole cyst out just so that it doesn't
fill back up because if you leave some
of that cystic lining you could
potentially end up regrowing a tumor
later okay good news is is that most of
the time these are benign tumors it's
just good to get these things taken off
just so you don't have to worry exactly
all right Coco
we'll be right back
there you go
she's really chill can you sit oh that's
a good girl this mask mom is describing
it as having clear fluids so I think
it's a sweat gland tumor those are
always fun
they deflate it it fills back up they
deflate it it's like Groundhog's Day you
know sometimes we'll just get that out
do you sweepy
Coco's a big girl 117 pounds we have a
little office tradition that helps us
determine who gets to do the honors of
lifting her onto the table Paper Rock
City
blah
blah blah so we gotta let this stop do I
ever lose I always win yeah I'm strong
oh Coco you're cute she is cute
see how big this little cyst is this
mask looks like a typical sweat gland
tumor these are benign they're not
cancerous yeah it looks kind of
translucent but if it were to rupture
and get infected it'll create a problem
for Coco so I'm gonna take it off today
we'll pick a balloon filled with water
hmm there's a bleeder ah I got you
gotcha there it is it's like a unicorn
horn off say goodbye to your little
friend
Coco's mask came off just fine and now
we get to cut into it
oh a little bit squared up
a little fluid came out it was just like
brain tumor see little holes in there
it actually is pretty Joya finds the
Beauty and the nastiest things sometimes
we got that thing off and I'm sure Coco
feels a lot better it won't come back
since I got all of the the cystic wall
it's gone gone for good
gone for good you're all done
all right Coco let's go
there's mom mama
[Music]
I do think it's a sweat gland tumor you
know I was able to get the whole capsule
out so it will not grow back here thank
you so so much this is such a relief
she's like why you guys talk I'm gonna
take another nap yeah I'm just gonna
take a nap right here
did you bring me a water too please Coco
doesn't really want to get up I think
she wants to stay with us I sort of have
that effect on animals or maybe it's the
sedation
motivation for you all right that's
right okay let's go all right yes legs
feel very heavy I can tell
I feel really relieved our quality of
life has just risen because we don't
have to worry about the bump on her head
and going to the vet every single month
for it
[Music]
you're out
are you ready Maggie
all righty I brought my dog Maggie May
to get a mask removed it's a two by two
mask that's just growing right out of
her belly so we need to get that taken
care of she is cute yeah she's my baby
this morning she would not come to me
she does not like to go to the vet she's
like put her head down and she's wagging
her tail
you know she knows something's going on
she's smart you have Miss Maggie this is
missing her ears she looked like a
gremlin when she was little she had real
dark ears and she would actually fit in
the palm of your hand so you've had her
had a long life she was five weeks old
when we brought her home
from the get-go Maggie she was attached
to me for some reason oh my Maggie
[Music]
Maggie She'll follow me everywhere I go
she has to be right in my lap if I take
a little trip she will want to go
outside every five minutes to see where
her daddy is she just cannot wait for me
to come home hey Maggie hey little girl
I never expected for me to love her as
much as I do she's pretty special
thanks everybody
here in the past couple years she
developed the growth underneath her
belly
and it wasn't too concerning we took her
to the vet and they said it was okay but
here in the past few months she started
scratching and it's starting to cause a
problem she's looking on her shoulder
right now she's breaking it open when
she scratches it her legs are getting
blowing on them you know she whines and
cries and so it's breaking my heart
I would love to have her around for
another five or six years we love her
that much that we we're willing to do
whatever we have to to get her fixed up
[Music]
you get that old thing taken care of
well let me take a look at this this
thing for you hey Maggie
that's pretty big isn't it
it's very firm oh I know we're real
afraid it's going to be real infected
because it's just not healing up now
yeah I mean it's got a little ulcer in
the center but it's probably just gotten
so big
when it happens they don't heal
over what's going on with Maggie May yet
but the look of this tumor is very
concerning we'll take her in the back
and then um okay
I'm gonna take it off for you hopefully
all right the way that this tumor looks
the way that it's firm the location of
it and the ulcer on it has me concerned
that this is something more serious
we're gonna take this giant tumor off
this tiny little dog I think it weighs
about 10 of her body weight it's very
firm I don't know if it's a form of
mammary tumor because there is a nipple
right there so it could be a like breast
cancer
Maggie May is a Chihuahua which they are
more likely to get mammary carcinomas
and the fact that she's you know much
older both Point me towards this being
something cancers
incision around this there's a lot of
free skin which is nice
it's like an eyeball coming out here
it's gonna be like an eyeball
[Music]
here it is it's coming you ready
it's gross all right I'm gonna close the
skin now I was able to remove all of
Maggie May's mask cleanly and because
this looks suspicious it's really
important that we get all of it out
completely
oh
it's very gnarly it's got a lot of
little bumpies on it it doesn't look
good
[Music]
yeah this looks like cancer
see all this tissue is like all normal
see the difference this is benign tumor
likely cancer it's pigmented like this
is all clear it's fairly organized I'm
really concerned that Maggie May's mass
is cancer but there's only one way to
find out so I have to send it out for
histopathology
I know you've been patiently waiting for
her
[Music]
everything went fine
it came out it did look abnormal I cut
into the center of it yeah yeah okay
yeah check it out don't you we're gonna
send it out yeah we'll send it out yeah
so we'll know what it is okay
I'm really scared it's going to end up
being cancer and
that would absolutely break my heart
those stitches can come out in two weeks
okay yep and then we'll we should know
back around that same time if not sooner
about them the mass
okay I hope it's nothing but if it is
we'll just have to we have to deal with
it
okay
because she's just like a little kid to
me
they they become your family
you want them to be able to stay around
as long as they can
all right Maggie let's go home
you're gonna feel a lot better
are you the best boy are you gonna put
them on the table I don't mind it off
laughs
you're so cute
oh there's some gunk in his paws good
job good job we got tail wags here's the
cheese I hate calling it cheese you're
doing your best
they shouldn't have that white material
in between
I'm getting uh discharge all over my
hands
why you got all this in your toes bro
angry allergic Paws my hands are like
covered in discharged and I'm unhappy
about it I would like to wash my hands
please
discharge from between the toes
it's fine it's great it's gonna be great
okay I feel new I feel better that's
just it's a part of the job
[Music]
and we have two dogs a female boxer
named Sadie and our French bulldog named
Natty Natty is our baby
she's just a fun-loving just a very very
outgoing dog
I should Maddie's only three years old
she should have a happy healthy life at
this point that's it but now that is has
this terrible skin problem
[Music]
Natty started losing hair around her
face and ear area
and then Nettie started to really itch
and then it went from itching to
scratching
more hair loss and the scabs and lesions
all our little sores
she's not her
[Music]
she was a wild child you could not keep
her still wanting to play with her balls
and Sadie all the time and now
she doesn't want to do anything just lay
around and sleep not my my little girl
that she used to be
as a vet tech I've seen many different
animals with skin problems and stuff
like that but I've never seen one as bad
as Nettie
we've taken Maddie to our personal vet
and we've tried different shampoos on
Earth
[Music]
Maddie's been on multiple skin
antibiotics steroids and nothing really
seems to help Nettie out
it makes you feel helpless
daddy means the world to us I've bend
over backwards for that girl
we're just hoping and praying that Dr
Joya can get us in the right direction
to fix it
[Music]
I'll look at her little Corkscrew tail
oh you just got the saddest little face
it's like a sphinx in a dog bag yeah
you don't look like the little Sphinx
Daddy doesn't have any hair so this
onesie is protecting her skin it's
keeping her warm keeping her from sun
damage and preventing her from
scratching herself and it's also super
cute
where did all your hair go what happened
to you your hair's gone you got these
crusties on your skin see this right
here that's that's what color she used
to be she was a little Blondie reddish
blonde
[Music]
so she looked normal at one point with
hair and everything oh yes like a normal
dog yes all over
interesting is she itchy now oh gotcha
she's very itchy okay yeah
foot pads are really thicky yeah
how does she feel overall I'm sure she
doesn't feel good no she's not her
normal self anymore she pretty much just
lays around and sleeps now
I see where they did the biopsy yeah and
it showed inflammation in the skin
basically and some infection but they
didn't come down on any specific disease
process so that's kind of unfortunate
for us nutty is a tough case her mom and
dad have done everything right they've
had her biopsy they've put her on
antibiotics and steroids they've done
everything that I would have done but it
seems like we're missing something blood
work was fine and everything else biopsy
blood work was good but still no
definite yeah the inconclusive biops
results really don't matter because the
fact is that Natty's just not getting
any better so I have to figure out
what's going on so we can help her
I want to get my girl back we're going
to help you
this poor thing we'll get you feeling
better and looking better I think this
is probably autoimmune disease were
there ever intact pustules on your skin
it looks like pemphigus
which is an autoimmune disease that can
affect dogs the cresting that she has on
her feet is really consistent with
pemphigus they'll get these really hard
pads he's sending Bulldogs it causes
this really thick kind of yellowish
crusting like she has on her body
pembicus is an autoimmune disease where
the body will attack the attachments
between the skin cells and even though
Natty's results were inconclusive she
looks just like pimpagus and my
experience is telling me that this is
what it is even without having to repeat
the biopsy what we're going to do today
is take a look at these slides from
underneath the little crusties and see
if we see any of those cells suggestive
of pemphigus without a definitive
diagnosis with the biopsy I'm taking
some samples of her skin to look at
under the microscope to see if I see
some suspicious cells that we typically
see with pemphigus I see a lot of
eosinophils which is often seen with
pemphigus she's got tons of eosinophils
all the pink dots those are eosinophilic
granules which she's pretty severe the
only way to diagnose pembicus is to
biopsy her but she's already been
biopsied and she's been through so much
I really just don't want to put her
through that again so I'm going to go
with my gut and start treating her
it looks like pemphigus
it's the most common form of autoimmune
skin disease that I see as a
dermatologist so I've treated it lots
yeah it's generally not life-threatening
but it's lifelong so I usually do a
combination of a steroid with another
anti-inflammatory drug or two depending
on how they do so that I can get my
patients off of steroids and not have to
keep them on steroids forever pemphigus
is not curable but with the medications
we can heal the skin the crush should
resolve the hair should regrow and
she'll do just fine just call me if
anything yeah if anything changes with
their we'll just collect all your skill
on this piece of paper here
it's not embarrassing we're going to
help you
I'm very very happy that we found out
what is going on but we can start
treating getting Addie fill in a whole
whole lot better
thank you so much thank you guys and I
heard you had the Frenchy socks on I was
like I got to yeah you got to yeah super
cute I love it I love it helpless was
the word
but Dr Joya
she's giving us some hope all right
honey
okay
[Music]
uh here he is he's loose
what happened it's okay we gotta clean
his butt better when he's down because
he stinks he's offended
Pancho is my wing man
come here I'm a travel nurse been
traveling around the country with him
he's got a sister they keep me company
just having them around really makes
traveling less stressful
I woke up this morning and looked at his
face and it was all swollen on one side
I saw him last night and I didn't think
there was anything there then I went to
go pet him this morning and I noticed
that there was a big lump on his face
got Poncho with you yeah perfect she
settled in her room come on Pancho I
hope there's not an issue and Dr Joya
can get his face back to normal
your dog is a cutie Cutie oh one side of
your face is Puffy how long has that
been there oh today just today woke up
and peeked at him and I was like oh come
here Poncho he's very sweet oh you're so
good
any like chance he could have had a
wound or an injury yeah his sister chews
on his face okay so so maybe it's not a
little puncture wound or something yeah
it could be soft tissue swelling from a
wound or you know like an abscess we'll
see if we can get some fluid out of it
and if we need to we may excise it to
let it drain to allow that okay pass
some fluid to come out things like this
happen it's not uncommon for dogs to
play a little rough with each other he
may have gotten this from wrestling
around with his sister and you know
maybe got a little puncture wound and
the swelling is now there because of
that but we can fix it just fine
[Music]
are you cute
blah
I can start a stick a needle and if you
think he'll tolerate that
you're strong enough can you do it I
know holding these guys
all right buddy
you're okay
it's okay there's some in there
[Music]
all right Poncho there's puss in there
this is bloody fluid but it looks a
little bit yellowish it probably is pus
you might want to apply pressure okay
I'm looking at the bloody fluid that I
aspirated from his face
and it looks like there's probably
infection on the side of his face
oh are you ready for your sedation
sneaky smells like sleepiness to me
Poncho's swollen cheek is likely an
abscess from playing a little rough with
his sister and got a little puncture
wound an abscess is just a pocket of pus
and his is pretty big so we need to take
care of it today I'm going to clean this
a little bit can I have a light a mother
man
we're going to try to remove this
abscess what I think is abscess you know
I don't think it's a tumor it's
definitely a fluid pocket there's bloody
fluid in there so I'm going to do a
little incision and try to flush all
that material out so it'll heal
we're gonna block it with lidocaine
and he sedated so I won't really notice
it
okay ready
oh it's coming
ew what nothing happened yet no I see
what's going to happen well I'm hoping I
don't see it because I don't want it in
my face
I've been around these enough to know
that I'm not going to be front and
center when she pops up I'm gonna take a
step back and just watch it happen there
is a pus pocket I'm just not where it is
where is your pocket
said anything good yeah there's a post
Market but it's I think it's so might be
like multifocal ones in there Pancho's
face we're hoping that there's going to
be a big explosion of Paws and all kinds
of game usually comes out
but this is one that's probably a little
bit older it has multifocal areas of pus
and not one big explosion is going to
happen today his tissue is very thick
and he's a lot of cellulitis on the side
of his face this is cellulitis that's
causing all the swelling cellulitis is
infection that's deep in the tissue I'm
really glad that Poncho's dad brought
him in today because if we didn't know
this infection could spread and it could
have ended up being something more
serious now we're just flushing out the
little pocket
oh God
[Music]
kind of Flushed all the blood and has
pocket out I'm prescribing an antibiotic
today to treat the infection so it
doesn't spread and hopefully we'll get
him back to looking normal again
oh
sploot
I think Pontius blue is the most
adorable thing I've ever seen his little
legs just
oh it's so precious you run out of gas
come on buggy come on
that's a good boy okay come on
[Music]
gotta walk off those drugs
he's so stinking cute I literally can't
form words at how cute he is he did so
good he is a fan favorite back there
he's such a good baby his skin is so
thick and it's a lot of cellulitis or
inflammation in the tissue itself so I
left it like this a little bit so it
will drain some okay all right baby call
me if you need anything okay okay
I'm happy they were able to drain the
abscess so that should clear up quickly
and Poncho's gonna be uh perfectly fine
but hopefully there's not too much
drainage going home I didn't bring
anything to cover the car seat
um driving my girlfriend's car so
hopefully I don't send her back with a
blood-stained seat
[Music]
are you good boy do you sit
oh okay I'm sorry I wasn't petting you
enough I kind of got the like hey hey
pay attention to me pet more
[Music]
I heard you had the cutest little Mojo
in here oh it's a smallest little thing
hi no little Mojo when I see little
cutesies like he is it just makes me
want to put them in my pocket like he's
the tiniest like bite-sized dog it's a
little Yorkie mix uh Patricia Yorkie
we're getting ready to do a DNA oh you
are fun I think Mojo's probably a teacup
something he looks sort of like a Morkie
to me those are Maltese Yorkies but he's
perfect the way that he is
hoarding case
Ally neglected mocho is an absolute
miracle
you say hi see I'm sleepy y'all cutting
into my nap time
the day that I picked Mojo up he was in
critical condition
foreign
he
weighed one pound
skin splitting open chunks of skin
falling off of his legs open wounds we
found that he had two broken legs then
the bones grew back wrong
but his front leg hangs to the side
deformed
and we didn't believe he would make it
through the week but he's a fighter
Miracles are still happening he's
fighting back it's been a journey it's
been five months he has beat all of the
odds he's just a part of us now he is a
member of our family I don't think we
could survive without him I mean we live
and breathe him we Joe
but he is not out of the woods he has
issues with his skin
when we got Mojo he had one of the worst
skin infections that we've ever seen so
he got a bath every night for two months
and medicated shampoo
but we noticed that it just doesn't seem
to be doing the trick he has a smell
that comes off of his skin and I just
feel that his skin is still unhealthy if
there is something we can do to make his
skin healthier we'll meet it head on
you would never believe this is the same
dog from your pictures and I mean we
probably don't even know exactly how old
he is either I guess yes it's between
six and seven years okay
sorry
watch those sounds you're making those
Tails wagonally likes you
know but she's snoring
hello Joe oh
do you think that he's itchy
he does with his real really strong leg
he does itch some with the spring coming
do you think that he's more itchy it
doesn't happen all the time honestly
this here is unusual I don't know so
this is where the hair has not come back
right and then he's got all these
blackheads yeah tons
those blackheads sometimes you can see
those with Demodex mites Steven X mites
are a type of Mite that live down in the
hair follicle and they can cause hair
loss and crusting on the skin because we
don't really know what's causing the
lesions on Mojo's skin it's really
important to check and be safer than
sorry that cause an odor we can give him
a bath and he still stinks swimming he
does have a little smelter he may still
have some infection has he been skin
scraped no okay I'll take him back and
do that I'm not really sure what's going
on with Mojo he's got a lot going on
with him and I'm going to start with
some cytologies to see if we can figure
this out we're gonna get you feeling
better we'll see what's going on with
this belly all right little baby I'm
gonna put you in my pocket oh okay
all right just be few minutes okay okay
all right
want to see my Emojis
[Laughter]
can I hold you you need some Mojo oh my
gosh can we make him our Clinic dog
and he just lives in the clinic he lives
in the clinic like a cat in my pocket
Mojo was so precious I mean any little
teeny dog that comes in you just have to
hold he is totally brightening my day
who doesn't want a Mojo in their life
it's great where all these blackheads
are I know the littlest dogs are the
Scorpius looks like a teddy bear maybe
hold that little leg
everybody grab some puppy I'm not sure
if this is mice or if this is infection
that's causing the skin lesions but
whatever it is can put a little bit of
extra stress on his body and suppress
his immune system a little bit so we
have to figure out what this is because
he's got a lot going on and we need to
get him feeling better
look at these skin scrapes
[Music]
I don't see any mice
so that's good
[Music]
a minute
all right looking at Mojo's skin slide
we've got some bacteria
he also has a little yeast
which can make him smelly a bit of
infection Mojo does not have any mites
which is good but he does have infection
on his skin he's both bacterial
infection and also yeast infection and
both of those things can sometimes come
up when you have something going on
internally that's suppresses an immune
response this is a little antibiotic
shot you're gonna have to be very brave
okay so I'm starting mojo on an oral
antibiotic as well as an antimicrobial
that'll take care of bacteria and yeast
for him so I'm hoping that that resolves
his infection
oh
all right here he is
I did scrape a couple spots so you'll
see a few little red raspberries but I
didn't find the might and then I did do
a slide from his skin and I found that
he has bacteria and yeast so that's
probably why he is a little bit of the
odor so we'll put him on an oral
anti-fungal and then we gave him a
little shot of an antibiotic injection I
mean there could be something else
that's going on
um you know with blackheads like
sometimes it's representative of
something going on internally you can
see it with different endocrine
disorders
our thyroid is necessary for initiating
antigen which is the growing phase of
the hair Cycles that's something that we
we should probably look into you can
have your family back draw the blood
panel it's totally fine to do and I
usually do a full thyroid panel because
sometimes just doing a snapshot look at
it isn't a complete picture and it can
be a little confusing so I'm working on
treating Mojo's infections first but I
do think it's a good idea for us to have
some blood work done so we can make sure
that there's nothing internal going on
such as thyroid disease because diseases
like that can cause them to have
recurrent infections and also make their
infections difficult to treat
you brightened my day Mojo I feel
hopeful with Mojo with the skin what we
can't see with the eyes she found the
scraping to find all the bacteria so
yeah I'm I'm feeling really positive
he'll come back here in a couple of
weeks hopefully this is going to help
that's another step in the right
direction you don't take a lifetime of
horrendous neglect and cure it in five
months six months seven months but we
are up for the challenge we're going to
give this baby the best life that he can
possibly have
come on girl Nana
fall down girl
it's like the complete opposite of last
time right we brought Natty back today
and see how she's doing
hi Daddy what you doing
you look a little bit better I think
she's not itching nearly as much her
hair is growing back she's playing with
our other dog Sadie again
and he's getting back to her old self
again and it's it's amazing
right and he went too far sister come on
hopefully when Dr Joy has seized Maddie
she's gonna be just as relieved
look at you
how are things going good
where did all your hair go what happened
to you Natty's the cutest little French
Bulldog she had crust all over her skin
almost zero hair so she looked normal at
one point with hair and everything yes
all over I diagnosed her with pemphigus
and started some treatment and she's
back today for me to take a look
the meds going okay really good okay one
two three
she's a little bitty thing let's see
underneath
oh Maddie
oh you look so much better
but even her foot pads they're looking
better softer all your crusts are good
he's back to playing and great very good
Natty looks amazing today I mean she's
not perfect of course she's still very
bald now you just need hair this is
Daddy's baby so he needed his baby girl
back to normal and she's almost there I
do see little little peach fuzz so
that's awesome backwards yeah you feel
it yeah you do you feel it it seems like
as the days go by it just more yeah
especially with pimpagus it might grow
back in a different color than what it
was before so you could see that I had a
white dog that we treated many years ago
during my residency and it came back as
a redhead after
I'm hopeful that over the next couple
months that she's going to continue to
improve and have hopefully a full coat
of hair soon so I just need to give her
a little more time
so when our plan is kind of to stay the
course with the cyclosporin because
that's what I'd like to maintain her on
over us having to Keep Her On chronic
steroids so our next step is going to be
to try to taper the steroid down and
then see you know where we land on as
far as her long-term dose pen Vegas is
very difficult to treat it does require
lifelong medications to suppress the
immune response but if I can control
Natty's disease with other medications I
should be able to taper the steroid down
to a very low dose I'm really pleased
with where she is it takes a little
while but already not having the crust
and not being like fire engine red is a
very big plus you've done a great job
with her this is one of my favorite
diseases to treat
I like it because sometimes it's
misdiagnosed and you know it takes
little patience to treat but when you
get them on the right treatment they do
really well and they look great I think
we're getting where we need to be with
Maddie I really do
all right little princess thank you for
coming in to see me I've been thinking
about her
it feels great to know that everything's
going really good when I come home from
work now and actually jumping at the
gate whining crying like she used to
she's happy to see you
that's our old Natty
come on
good boy
you're so sweet you're so cute I can't
deal
good morning good morning you got Maggie
May here I got her perfect well if you'd
like to
like to all right I brought Maggie May
in today she's all healed up and we're
gonna find out whether Maggie's tumor
was malignant or not hopefully this is
gonna be good news
see this little baby
I'm good how has she been doing she's
doing great everything healed okay she's
picked up a little bit away good Maggie
May had a suspicious looking tumor that
I removed I don't know if it's a form of
mammary tumor so it could be a like
breast cancer I did not like the look of
it so I sent it out and I have the
results today it's not just fat it
doesn't look good so I got the report
back
and it's kind of one of those good news
bad news situations
the bad news is it is a form of cancer
it's a type of mammary carcinoma
it doesn't actually go to distant sites
so it shouldn't metastasize or spread
anywhere internally so it's unlikely
that it would go to the liver or the
spleen or anywhere else so you know we
just need to monitor the site for local
recurrency
this is the best news that we could have
um you know with something like this so
it is cancer but it's not a cancer that
should take her life and goes you know
somewhere internally so that's really
good yeah that's great yeah and at this
age I mean you know that's great
you would never guess she's 13 she
doesn't look like that I always hate to
give the news of cancer to a mom or dad
but in Maggie's case this is somewhat
good news it is cancer but it's a type
of cancer that's unlikely to spread
internally to other parts of the body
we're gonna have to keep an eye on it
but I think that she's going to have
plenty more time with her dad
I can tell she loves you that's Daddy's
baby I'd love to have her around for
another five or six or seven years yeah
absolutely she's the loving this dog you
know at this point it's really just
about you know keeping her as happy and
healthy and loving on her as much as you
can if I'm home she's in my lap I'm like
one of those big guys that's got a
little chihuahua in his arm and I never
expected to have a five pound Chihuahua
that I love her Maggie's my baby my
sweet girl
you just go home and be loved on by your
daddy that's all she's like she's so
sweet looks like a puppy you're Forever
Young I'm optimistic about it Dr Julia
said that it's the kind of cancer that
will stay in the one spot so I really do
believe we're going to have Maggie May
for many years to come
all right Maggie let's go home
[Music]
how's little Mojo he's doing great
when I first met Mojo he was a sweet
little rescue that had come from a
horrendous situation and he had terrible
skin lesions that turned out to be
bacterial and fungal infection this here
is unusual I don't know we've been
treating that and I think that he's been
doing a lot better but I can't wait to
see him in person how
[Music]
little Mojo
he looks so much better he looks so good
you look so clean mom does a good job
with you look at all this hair you have
just a little red through there but
you're doing a great job with him and
he's very well loved very well loved
Mojo looks great today I'm excited to
see that his hair is regrowing that he
doesn't have any lesions on his skin and
he's more active and he just looks
wonderful and he's doing well has he
gained weight he looks bigger he's I've
gained four four more ounces the last
time that we seen Dr Joya she
recommended some blood work be done with
his primary physician you can have your
family back draw the blood panel it's
totally fine to do and I usually do a
full thyroid panel luckily we found out
that he had an extremely underactive
thyroid and now he's on medications for
thyroid and he's doing great that's such
great news that we figured out that he
had hypothyroidism because that was one
of the things I was thinking you know
his hair isn't skin isn't flaking
anymore retaining his body heat yeah
easy for you does he have a little more
energy oh you wouldn't believe it Mojo
does have hypothyroidism but this is a
very treatable endocrine disorder it's a
disease where the thyroid produces too
little hormone and if you supplement it
they do quite well and they feel so much
better and it can really make a huge
impact on their quality of life
um well thank you for bringing them in
you do just such a great job thank you
he's doing great I mean his skin and
hair coat feel wonderful continuous
topical therapy and if you have any
issues if you notice any skin problems
or any itchiness in the future I'm here
to help it feels great to be part of
Mojo's story he's kind of a larger than
life character and a tiny little dog
body and it's just great to be a part of
that to see Mojo living his best life
now with so much care and attention is
really great so sweet Mojo is doing
great we didn't think he was going to
live a week and he's still with us and
loving life the infection is completely
cleared from his skin there's no more
fungal bacteria and now he's on
medications for thyroid his energy level
is through the roof he's doing great and
I hope Dr Joya understands the impact
that she's had on his light catching you
know but his illnesses were it's just
made all the difference in his little
world and he's living his best life yet
okay buddy
what's up
[Music]
come on
guys in the past couple months Natty has
done a 180 to him no
no no
before Natty literally was bald your
hair's gone you got these crusties on
your skin she had lesions all over her
body her attitude was down in the dumps
she didn't want to play she didn't
really want to eat she didn't want to do
anything but just lay in sleep but now
[Music]
she's back
her hair is coming back her attitude
everything is just amazing now Nettie
wants to play with her sister go for
walks she loves her tennis balls
good girl as of our last visit with Dr
Julia we have cut off one of the term
medications but we will still have to
keep her on one pretty much the rest of
her life she's not a fan but she does
take it she's like oh man not again
let's see that go for it
walk around I think she knows in a sense
if I take my medicine I'll be happy and
healthy
and I don't think it would have been
possible if we didn't go see Dr Julia
she helped us out and I'm just thankful
good catch babe
[Music]